with all due respect that pigeon is
clearly a rayjay
hi gina linetti the human form of the
100 emoji
are you supposed to be babysitting gina
it doesn't need my help she's over there
dazzling some psychologists
all men are at least 30 attracted to me
my mother
cried the day i was born because she
knew she would never be better than me
at any given moment i'm thinking about
one thing richard dreyfuss
hunkered over eating dog food i feel
like i'm
the paris of people complete overlap of
ego and
id it's been theorized but i never
thought i'd see it
i'm exquisite i did not follow you to pr
to watch you quit
i followed you because you're great and
because you make everything you touch
better
and i figured pr would be the easiest
path to launching my reality show
lynnetti set go
i thought your reality show was to be
called gina in a bottle
no that was my fragrance line keep up
you should make me your campaign manager
i was born for politics i have great
hair
and i love lying hey
gina what are you thinking about right
now i was thinking how i would make the
perfect american president
based upon my skill set dance ability
and bloodlust that is
fascinating ashanti
nobody can ever know that we had sex all
right i have spent
years cultivating a reputation as
someone who sleeps with
bike messengers or better i'm sorry
i just don't think this is something
you're good at what the only thing i'm
not good at is modesty
because i'm great at it i'm a higher
level of being like her from the movie
her
i really miss these people the whole
crew jake
terry i forget all their other names
your problem is not that you're troubled
or at risk
or bad dressers is that trucker hat
still
come on your problem is that you don't
have
passion for anything my life
turned around when i found my passion
and today well i hope to inspire you
with
[Music]
you are it no matter what they say
words can't bring you down
you are beautiful in every single way
what are we thinking nothing bad ever
happens to me i have a crystal in my
pocket at all times
charles turn that music off we gotta
send someone in as a customer get her to
open up start gospel send me
i'm a gossip surgeon i can get anything
out of anyone you can't go undercover
you're not a cop
how am i not a cop terry cause they
don't have a badge being a cop is a
state of mind
it's definitely not i grew up forging
report cards
if people knew how smart i was it would
have been harder to control them
the english language cannot fully
capture the depth and complexity of my
thoughts so
i'm incorporating emoji into my speech
to better express myself
winky face all i'm saying is a if not
the voice of the streets is
this isn't gonna work gina maddie is the
ultimate human slash genius thank you
i would spend my five thousand dollars
to buy backstage passes to brittany
and then i'd ask her one question you
think you're better dancing than me
did you have enough time to read at all
yes
gina made me call people and tell them
she was dead to see how they'd react
is she crying is she crying a little
you should be wailing you stone cold
[ __ ]
now call my other grandma gina linetti
is the real hero here
there's a gina lynette more of a state
of mind like in a way we were all gina
linetti today
gina let's take this gina to the
hospital
apparently you were just named spring
dance princess somehow
mm-hmm what am i always telling you guys
i'm royalty
i'm gina linetti and i approve this
message over one million people are
living their lives according to the gene
amendments they're like the ten
commandments only there's more and
they're better if i die turn my tweets
into a book
buy a mic right now i drop it
amy and i are going to my mom's house
for my birthday adults don't care about
their birthdays
you came to work last year on a horse
once again my advice has like
saved the city have you thought this
through not at all
and yet checkmate that was completely
illegal that's not at all how the queen
moves that's how this queen moves
checkmate it's against the rules of
chess well gina lynette done reinvented
the game uh what's this meeting all
about i've got a full workload today i
didn't call it
i thought you did what i did no such
thing so neither of you called it then
who did
oh sheila that was awesome okay just
stay here
wow i can't believe i executed that to
perfection that was amazing gina what's
this all about
i wanted to make one final grand
entrance final what do you mean
i've decided to leave the nine-nine
which is why
oh okay
[Music]
i'm handing in my two weeks notice
i don't understand what are you gonna do
i'm not sure but jake convinced me it
was time to start a new chapter it was
time to
spread my wings and fly i'm an angel
i'm an angel i'm an angel this is crazy
i can't imagine a nine-nine without you
don't worry i have a parting gift for
all of you
i printed time for gina's opinion
hoodies for you with your names on them
uh there you go oh that's fun so like
time for jake's opinion what are you
insane no
it says time for gina's opinion in large
text on the back
and then your names are stitched really
tiny on the front ah i had to guess at
some of the spellings
arnie but that's not all over the next
two weeks i will be leaving
each of you with a signature gina moment
something so shocking that it will stay
with you for the rest of your lives
much like this interpretive dance piece
entitled
the lenexit this dance will be performed
in four movements each one expressing
one aspect of my personality
[Music]
uh
[Music]
awesome was that the first movement what
are you crazy no that's the warm-up
each movement is 45 minutes oh damn hit
it
i see we got eight recruits for the
junior police program outstanding
thank you sir but as important as your
praise is to me it should
actually go to gina she's the one that
got through to the kids yes i am
amazing and i only asked for one thing
in repayment
a 600 race we're like rock stars to
these people
they're gonna go nuts it's like ah
nicely done aubry is great we are going
to dinner again tonight
i owe you an apology you're a great
matchmaker thank you
and you know what i'm just glad that you
found the courage
to tell me how great i am it means so
much whatever
have a fun day
like chances
you